who murdered Jimmy Lee Jackson
white law man who abuses the law to
terrorize
every white politician
who feeds on Prejudice and hatred
for a white preacher who preaches the
Bible and stays silent before his white
congregation
who murdered Jimmy Lee Jackson
Ezra negro man and woman who stands by
without joining this fight as their
brothers and sisters are humiliated
brutalized and ripped from this Earth
when I heard
President Kennedy had been shot and
killed
and when I heard just yesterday
that Malcolm X
who stood in this very church just three
weeks ago had been shot and killed
I turned to my wife Coretta and said the
same thing I often say when one of our
leaders is struck down
our lives are not fully lived
if we're not willing to Die For Those we
love
and for what we believe
but today Jimmy
we're doing the living and you've done
the dying dear brother
we will not let your sacrifice pass in
vain dear brother
we will not let it go
we will finish what you were after we
will get what you were denied
we will vote we will put these men out
of office we will take that power we
will win when you were slaughtered and
fall
you that build all other guns
you the Builder that plays
just want you to know
that I see through your mess
you have never done nothing
about to build to destroy
Troopers withdrawal
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
whispering to them that regardless of
their lot in life
they can at least be triumphant in the
knowledge that their whiteness makes
them Superior to Blackness but we know
the truth
you know the truth and we will go
forward to that truth to Freedom
[Applause]
we will not be stopped
we will
we were all right
we will Notch to demand treatment as
full citizens we will March until the
viciousness and the Darkness gives way
to the life of righteousness
no man
no myth no malaise will stop this
Movement we forbid it for we know that
it is this darkness that murders the
best in us and the best of us
whether Jimmy Lee Jackson
or James Reed
to fall blameless little girls
struck down before they had even begun
you may ask
when will we be free of this Darkness I
say to you today my brothers and sisters
despite the pain despite the tears our
freedom will soon be upon us
for truth rush to Earth will rise again
[Music]
when will we be free
soon and very soon because you shall
reap what you sow
[Applause]
[Music]
when will we be free
soon and very soon
because no lie can live forever
[Music]
when will we
will we soon and very soon